the worry of recent days had
overshadowed many holidays but tourists
heading back to england
can carry on sunbathing with no fear of
quarantine back home
portugal for now at least will remain on
the safe travel list
i'm really glad because i very nearly
bought a flight home for a thousand
pounds the other day
um so i'm really happy and i think it's
a sensible decision
my son um and his girlfriends and their
cousins
are due to fly out at 6 35 tomorrow
morning
and we've been stressing about it for
the last week
and literally it has made my day
and obviously was waiting and waiting uh
got other friends coming out here next
week as well
so they're over the moon now that when
they arrived and not got quieting
but if you thought the corpse would be
popping on every table in this
restaurant full of uk visitors you'd be
wrong
wales and scotland have decided
quarantine should be imposed
and uncertainty about what was to come
across the united kingdom
sent many tourists home early in some
cases forking out huge sums
for a plane ticket and splitting
families my brother has now rushed home
today and obviously paid
a ridiculous amount for a flight to get
home and cut his holiday short from
i don't know two weeks to four or five
days my dad had to go home and my three
brothers
so they my dad had to cut his holiday
short
from a week to like four or five days so
one can only imagine how those tourists
already back
or heading back to england early are now
feeling
the change of plan for them wasn't
necessary after all
and business owners here who rely on uk
travelers fear the worry of this week
will put people off making future plans
to come
you see in people's faces the fear
the fear is so it's so painful because
you know for one minute to the other you
have to pack up your kids and say kids
you cannot be in the pool anymore
we have to go back home and book very
expensive flights from one minute to the
other
those heading to wales will have had no
time to change plans with the new rules
coming in
at 4am friday there's a day's grace for
those heading to scotland
with the cut-off saturday morning many
will be asking how different governments
could come to such
different conclusions over quarantine
some tourists from the uk forced to
self-isolate
others not and even the relief for those
travelers from england will be tempered
by the knowledge the situation will be
monitored daily
and could change none of which will
engender confidence in travel
a blow to both tourists and the tourism
industry abroad
michelle clifford sky news the algarve
portugal